[موسيقى]
تحتاج بالتأكيد إلى تذكر اسمه
إنها اللمسة الأولى رائعة للغاية
وقد تكون أفضل
من اللمسة الأولى لصلاح بالفعل
وهو أعسر بحت يمكنه
ركلها بيمينه لكنه
أعتقد  إنه يصمم لعبته
أكثر فأكثر على
صلاح ديفيد كان الأمر مثل ديفيد سيلفا
أوم
وكلاعب شاب اعتاد أن يلعب
وسط خط الوسط وكان هو
يشبه إلى حد كبير
روي كين الذي كان يتمتع بتقنية عالية للغاية ، كان سيقذفك إلى
النصف.  ثم أركض بالكرة التي
تضحك عليك وضربها في
الزاوية ، لكن هل هو كبر في السن
لأنه لم يكن كبيرًا بما يكفي ليلعب
وسط خط الوسط في
كرة القدم الممتازة ، ظهر وصلاح ثم ظهر
المهاجم من الداخل إلى الخارج
ظهر المهاجمون المقلوبون تدريجيًا
إلى الجانب الأيمن وأم ، والآن
لديه رؤية سامية وشجاعة
لخسارة الكرة والذهاب واستعادتها مرة
أخرى وهو أمر من نوعية ليفربول للغاية
حيث استعاد الكرة مرة أخرى في اثنين و  نصف
ثانية وخسرها ،
لقد نما للتو أربع بوصات هذا العام
عندما كان قد وقع بالفعل ولعب مع
ليفربول في هذه المرحلة ، لذا لم يكن قد
وقع لأنه كان كبيرًا ، لذا كان عليه أن
يفعل كل هذه المشاكل
كرجل صغير
وهو شاب ناري صغير
وهذا هو الشيء وهو الآن
ينمو في الصفات البدنية
لدرجة أنه يتجاوز ذلك الحاجز
لدخول الدوري الممتاز حتى يتمكن الآن من تجاوز
تسعة أمتار ونصف المتر في الثانية
في شروط العدو ويمكنه الآن  يقوم بأكثر
من 40 عدوًا سريعًا للعبة ، وتلك
الأشياء الفسيولوجية أثناء نموه
في جسده
والتي كل ما عليه أن يعمل عليه
هي العناصر التكتيكية
لتجربة اللعب في كرة القدم للرجال
وسيطير
[موسيقى]